so what would you guys
date someone like kim kardashian that
has had
that has had um a sex tape on the
internet i think we can all agree on
this i think we all wouldn't
yeah
[Music]
no no comment yeah but clearly that
means
you found it yeah yeah
it's gonna come back out i mean yeah but
[ __ ]
um
i mean yeah well but i don't know like
that was your past in it like i guess
for some people you have to do what
you've got to do to make one unit so i
mean if you change yes yeah but men have
to like get a job
[Music]
like you can make money in other ways
you can go work at mcdonald's
it's just it's just they want fast money
it's not
like if that happens to a dude he's just
homeless
oh damn
drink to that drink
well
so so you would date a girl that had
like a sex tape like that
okay
like we're saying this now but that this
came okay we would we would
you would we would but would you marry
or do dates that's the question
marina is there
i feel like i don't know let's say
you're talking and later on later on i
can find out that's what she did
like i don't know that's the question
because like
would it be easier for you to like leave
or would you actually stay like that's
where the problem is
i mean
you know everything about her already so
you going to marry her like you you know
everything she's done but with another
girl i mean
i'm not gonna lie i probably would i
probably would you probably still would
yeah
why like why wouldn't you pick a girl
that like doesn't have that like oh if
that was a girl
it's just interesting to me because
kanye could have anyone he's a
billionaire like why is he picking a
girl that's for the streets
she's made so much money though so
either way she's actually an independent
woman regardless of what she's that's
why the wi-fi
yeah but then again
that kind of stuff is a bit of a wild
yeah but i mean
do you mention do you guys care about a
girl's money
no
well not at this point but it's nice if
you have money in it yeah it's not just
don't be flashing in my face and saying
i don't need you i don't do this i don't
i can do it like is is a woman's ceo
like hot to you yeah yeah
really
yeah independent really
because i haven't
i've always heard from guys that they
don't care about a girl's money so it's
interesting that you guys have the
opposite point of view it just depends
on the situation
so for example like
if i'm older and i'm trying to get my
stuff together
and
she hasn't like for example isn't hasn't
been really ambitious
then why would i like go for her because
it's not really in like i'm not going to
elevate myself to a different point in
life
with her but she's not really she
doesn't have money she's not like
ambitious no points
so what do you think would you date a
guy
that had a sex tape
um
[Music]
would i
[Music]
i mean
if it's not something he's trying to do
again
like on a regular then yeah i think i
would really yeah oh my god depends
though it really it really does depend
is it leaked like is it something you're
doing like every year
it needs to have content is that what
they don't it's i don't know difficulty
we're growing yeah
i mean
even nowadays like people are just
recording themselves like it's normal
like that's what i'm saying it's like
it's not if you've got elite kozak
like guys are just being
yeah
yeah but like you don't think it's kind
of on the girl to vet the guys she
sleeps with and does that with like
doesn't that kind of say something about
her decision-making abilities
i mean it depends on the situation again
because if it's like a past thing and
it's not going to be
every week or he's going out to do that
or i'm seeing it somewhere else or my
friend's sending it to me then yeah yeah
it's a bit different but if he made
money and income because of right how
kim kaden then
i don't know okay so now the other
question do you guys think that
someone's past matters
to an extent yes
yes yes
obviously it does the reason i say it
does is because
you can enjoy your young ages but don't
destroy it yeah like yeah you can have
fun and do whatever like
but if you just go and be loose and just
do everything like it's gonna be hard to
get like
um like the in this day nation some
girls that have bc's that are older than
their age so it's like by the time they
get into that stage where they want to
like settle down because you've been
around it's like no one's going to take
you seriously yeah maybe one guy will
it'll be very hard to get maybe one
ah there's always hope for everyone in
it but you know like maybe one guy like
well but it's like even if now like you
marry that girl imagine walking down the
road oh yeah like she slot me off in the
block oh yeah she did
that's something that's not for you
no but that's something you're gonna
have to live with like for the rest of
your life do you get it yeah and
like even if you marry her yeah it's
like cool you have to go through all
this time to marry the girl it took me
what two weeks just to get slops you get
it so it's like
well it's kind of like she gave
something
to that guy for free and she's making
you like pay for it yeah yeah
i'm trying to see
if you've got the right person for you
man
whatever you're ready to deal with
yeah i mean if two jbags meet then they
can be together in it
yeah because they both know what they're
on that's crazy yeah you know i would
say though i would say you like what you
like so
if there's a girl that you really like
but her past is crazy
that's not really gonna matter too tough
because
you liking her factors more than what
she's done with other people before i
think it depends on like what happens
between when you've started speaking to
her i mean yeah and then moving onwards
if it's if it's still wild then
you're gonna throw that away jesus
christ sorry guys
do you guys do you guys ask girls that
you're saying like about what they've
done before or do you just you're like
see no either evil hear no evil like i
don't want to know really i think i
think when you're when you're going to
speak to a girl
someone knows something do you i mean so
you don't really even have to ask
directly
you can kind of get
a sense of who someone is
just about the way they speak and where
they talk and the way their friends
speak about them and stuff like that
yeah they don't really have
them directly to kind of gauge what's
going on more time they can lie as well
yeah they can actually live maybe would
you know if they're lying
you never know exactly if i tell you
three like you can't argue with me like
a lot of girls you know every single
person a lot of girls will say that pc
is one it's really 20.
because they know that because they know
but that's actually some girls some
girls will like saying that their bc is
one and if you oh that's calm you get to
know her and then
she didn't realize she's putting all the
tricks out of the bag
like sometimes like even your boys even
your boys would be like no
she's active bro like what are you doing
bc is one huh you told me that and then
that's when that's when that problem's
gonna start in it because like they know
that the type of guy you are you're not
gonna deal with a girl that's like out
there so they're gonna have to lie to
you but you that's something you never
know mm-hmm
you can't avoid in certain situations
mm-hmm
but okay so
bc is one thing right
like like so girl what she's done
but i think it takes it to another level
when it's on the internet like i have
brothers i would never tell them to deal
with a girl that has any sort of only
fans any sort of sex tape on the
internet like ever
because like your kids are going to see
that one day
and like that's who you're seeing now
with kim kardashian like look at the
like that she has to have that
conversation with all four of her kids
like can you imagine having a mom with
an off like an only fans
[Music]
you knew the
[Laughter]
no but if we're talking about like kim k
of course like
her sex tape is gonna be out there
because she's really like up there but
if we're talking back about like a
normal person
i think it's gonna go away you're not
gonna like find a video like of someone
that you don't really know about
mm-hmm i think things definitely like
brush over like think think about coming
along i think about school that time
stuff gets sent around and said no do
you even remember that no look look at
oshkosh bro now
because of what she's done exactly but
like not everyone's going to be popping
that's right
[Music]
i think there's exceptions to every rule
right but
it's still like in general like i just
don't know why as a guy you'd want to
deal with that do you think that guys
put up with like bad behavior because a
chick is like really good looking some
people do yeah i think it's more easier
to look over yeah you know like let's
say like you bagged
let's say you've backed one
let's say you've had one lengthening now
and it's like the girl's toxic but
because she's lengthy you know like if
you have her by her side i'm animal like
yeah i rate your thing so when you go
behind closed doors she might be so
toxic like bro like no one's meant to be
going through that but because she's
laying like she that's what you're like
you're putting up with it because you
just want to keep her there did you get
it
so yeah
i think a lot of guys care about like
other like guys validating them that's
why they put up with it
but and that's how we'll send from but
even now like girls of bad behavior like
all that toxic [ __ ] like it's normalized
now so
a lot of guys tend to look for that now
it's just crazy yeah some guys like it
man
i have been saying that every show that
i think there's a type of guy that likes
girls that are a little bit mean to them
yeah they're all mean and keep them keen
like no but i don't
like dad next question next question no
like
no it will i just like will smith okay
take will smith take no no let's let's
just use him as an example look at this
you cannot tell me that will smith did
not have the option to pick a girl that
was nice to him when he was on the fresh
prince of freaking bel-air
he could have had his pick of what like
lined up
and he picked the one girl
that like is borderline and like abusive
to him mentally she was in love with
tupac yeah she was in love with someone
else well you're shown like at the
beginning because what you're shown like
what someone decides to show you could
be completely different than what they
really are do i mean it's like years
down the line it could be tomorrow but
it could be years down she was like
crying on their wedding day what do you
mean
so look how long they would have been
for and obviously there's signs
if you and stuff but
like it
yeah
now will smith went up on the stage i
actually smacked some of her and she
said that she still did all that with a
madness like that's crazy i could never
have a goal that like i'd do that for my
man just listen no yes mama made a joke
about your your your head
no no no no
i'm not trying to violently no mama made
a joke about your head
no no but no but keep it cool that's one
thing another guy went into your wife
you could even duck him down to do
nothing like i can't let your waist man
no no violet i'll be so real will smith
i love fresh version bella bro like
that's my guy but after i saw that and i
saw everything
i'm not gonna lie
there's levels to that you're not gonna
go for the guy bro what are you gonna go
for the guy first her bro but that's
what i'm saying if you're not gonna go
for the guy that went into your wife
don't go for no one that chats about
your wife bro yeah
i think there's there's levels in there
yeah you sat right there
he was sat right there imagine you're
sitting there with your wife bro and
someone
it's a bit says than just that yeah
but bro but there's a bit more in the
marriage you still let bro you bro your
wife told you in your face on flipping
the whole world knew it bro
you bro i dropped another guy because
what i needed some sort of security yeah
but he made the house he bought a house
for her bro whether you meet one pasta
is like that's different what i'm saying
to you is let's say you're sitting there
with your wife right now and i make a
joke a personal joke but to you to me
that's what chris is meant to do
yeah he literally is on the show to
present that's jokes
that's his job so if you take it how you
take it he literally does that for a
living yeah everyone has to know that
[Music]
she's going through this this and that
you're the other chris christopher was
just a joke do you mean yeah
how is chris rock supposed to know she
had an alopecia he doesn't care
he just have to phone me handed it
differently like even if you messed up
by not slapping a grown man on this like
when he grabbed his oscar whatever it is
tell everyone that look that was not
okay mm-hmm like in front of everyone
that he could have
but like
he was just acting up he was acting our
character like yo yeah you just trying
to pull a point
maybe if you're like
you know 18 but
i'm sorry if like a grown ass man you
don't you're not in control enough of
your emotions tonight that's what i'm
trying to say because it was in front of
them nice it's hard
it's hard that was a big audience
yeah so then so then so then grow a pair
and leave don't you don't have to like
you don't have to put up with that
and like like imagine imagine okay if
jada was a dude okay and and or let's
say will smith did it he hooks up with a
20 year old
that is addicted to drugs that they took
in from the time he was like 15. she was
like 15 and then he sleeps with her
all right
like you don't you think the world would
have like
no he would be done yeah and it's such a
double standard
yeah
and it's like like she's almost i would
say predatory to be honest an
entanglement she said
an entanglement that would
she give it a whole different meaning